we're going to do a hard segue the
hardest of hard segways do it i'm sorry
because i have to
because there was a trend on twitter my
friends i give you
jenk yuger
of the young turks claiming he could
beat joe rogan in a fight
all right okay that's mma celebrity
match just uh just for everybody you
know uh jenk is an overweight
progressive uh youtube host and joe
rogan is not only an mma commentator but
he used to fight mma and he trains and
he has a gym
and he is massively ripped
but we have this tweet
mr m says
i will make a 1 000 donation to your
trash network or your or your charity of
choice to see you call rogan who is not
only the most successful podcast in
history but also a black belt in mma a
loser to his face and jankuger said deal
easiest one thousand dollars i've ever
made you think he's going to assault me
sure whatever that's incredibly dumb but
also wouldn't work i'm much larger than
joe and i've fought my whole life i'd
end him
but grown-ups don't do that i'll send
you the p.o box to send the check later
i'll end him
this is
wow a whole new level of stupid but come
on man is this is this this is the
political discourse we get in this
country yes let me let me let me pull up
we got we got another tweet here let me
see if it loads
jenker says if joe rogan believes the
government is violating your bodily
autonomy is that the government
violating your bodily autonomy as
tyranny then he must be furious about
anti-choice christian mullahs in his
country if he isn't then he's an effing
hypocrite sucking up to his right wing
audience out of either stupidity or
cowardice except i'm pretty sure joe
rogan is pro-choice pro-ubi pro bernie
sanders this is what these people don't
get
jank huger is plastic
he represents
the the the non-player character
that dominates our political discourse i
for instance
pro-choice
vax mandates are wrong because it's a
liberty-minded approach not a
traditional value-minded approach but
gen doesn't know or care and so the
parent factions that the democrats and
the republicans now republicans mostly
not so much because trump really just
splattered that whole party
changing it
very
different nowadays
but the establishment democrats only
seem to recognize dichotomies
so jan kuer goes on his show and says
either you agree with us you're you're
on our side or no matter what else
you're wrong even if what you're saying
is scientifically true or factually
correct doesn't matter and so they'll
come out and it just what's the point of
this tweet jack did you just watch joe
rogan's podcast well this is i mean this
is the point of the tweet
do we talk about it on something
but but good i'm you know i understand
that and i'm fine with it you know why
we need to explain to people who are
watching give them something they can
share and say my friends you deserve
actual political debates
what jenk is saying here
most likely is driven by i i will say
hanlon's razor never attribute to mouse
that which can be explained by
incompetence or attributed to
incompetence perhaps he's just
not that smart however gen hugo runs a
multi-million dollar network that's
massive and you need to have abilities
and passion and drive to do something
like that so that says to me jank knows
he's misleading his audience he knows
he's pushing trash to fill their minds
with garbage that will not move this
country forward rogan's a black belt in
jiu-jitsu i believe he i know he's a
kickboxer i don't know if he practices
but i mean i think chank just doesn't
understand
that if he's really being serious here
it sounds like like a high school
athlete who's like in their 30s or 40s
and is a little overweight and still
talks about how badass they are yeah
i don't know i don't know chang i don't
know maybe he's a great fighter i don't
know he's a union buster
this is the problem we have
the young the young turks are on youtube
tv they're propped up by youtube they
have massive investment and they are as
fake as they come this is this is
they're saying i used to love him man
and then in the 2007 2006 they were like
speaking out against the war in iraq
he was revolutionary in a good way it's
not even i don't it's look i don't know
if you've seen this but have you noticed
a change in people
like something changed yeah people like
like like jang for instance
you know uh i've known him for a long
time and not like my friends or anything
but you know i've had me on a show a
couple times i saw him at vidcon several
years ago and he walked up and he was
like hey how's it going we show cans and
we talked about youtube and metrics and
i was doing my youtube channel and i was
doing what i was doing and then two
years later at politicon he's screaming
in my face just like screaming at me and
i'm like why are you yelling at me like
dude what's going on i should clarify
joe's not a kickboxer taekwondo that's
what i meant to say taekwondo oh really
he's taekwondo he won a tournament like
in his late teens early 20s and then he
kind of got out of the game after that
he's getting hit too much dude is ripped
yeah he's a maniac
but so so something happened to people
man and i don't i don't know what yeah
i'm not this isn't like a strong
explanation but i think part of it does
have to do with social media
and the way that it's sort of like
i i i to me that matches up with the
timeline of like the politics has gotten
much more divisive like democrats and
republicans have moved away from the
middle and are like much more outside of
the middle but have you seen the pew
research the the trends on this or yeah
it's democrats not republicans
republicans are slightly more moderate i
thought it was democrats more than
republicans but republicans also did it
republicans shifted leftward a great
deal from like you know during the 2000s
into the early 2010s yeah and then moved
only a little bit to the right okay so
depending on what time frame you're
using but based on where republicans
were in the 90s into the 2000s they're
actually much further left than yeah
than they traditionally have been
they're progressives driving the speed
limit and one on and so on right exactly
yeah uh
yeah so but it definitely does like it
incentivizes conflict it discourages us
seeing uh the other side
and it's also like created this
phenomenon where like we're living in
these like separate realities where
they're like you know who is who is like
who are these people that both sides
still trust you know there's basically
no one none
so my favorite was i mentioned this for
many of you may have heard this but i'll
just you know just so you know when i
went on russell brand's show and he
asked me i was in russell brandt's show
he asked me about civil war
and you know i typically view this as
people are like they think they're going
to get me as though like i'm some shock
jock being like civil war and like being
on the table when i'm actually like
going through all of the details the
princeton professor the atlantic
articles the the conversations around
thucydides trap and what it means fourth
and fifth generational warfare all of
these very like you know specific
examples of why we are facing some kind
of civil conflict then you've got i'm
like first and foremost we had two
shootouts in the pacific northwest
between the left and the right i mean
that's kinetic conflict it's been going
on for years and getting worse and then
you have the storming of the capital and
all this stuff the comment section was
hilarious people on the right saying
tim's a leftist people on the left
saying tim's right wing
and i'm like well there you go there's
no middle there isn't for any real
conversation but the interesting thing
is libertarians are kind of like in the
middle because they're like all i care
about is freedom do you care about
freedom so i suppose i'll put it this
way
when i look at uh when we have
libertarians on the show with
conservatives they agree on so much
but the libertarians on the left do not
agree and the conservatives and liberals
do not agree and it really does feel
like
the overwhelming majority of the left as
we describe it be it establishment or
leftist is authoritarian masquerading as
libertarian because
no one will come out and claim to be an
authoritarian no one will do it it's not
going to win you any favors but then you
see people like hassan [ __ ] you know
you see the young turks you see vosh in
favor of rule by edict the president
issuing a decree and then everyone being
forced to adhere to it and they're
celebrating it
that's the definition of
authoritarianism
yeah what's the does everyone know the
dude quote i could never do it right
like when i'm weaker than you i ask for
you to follow the principles and then
when i'm stronger than you like i i
don't adhere to the principles because
it's good good for me i'm i'm yeah i'll
look it up but that but that's that's
exactly what the uh that's exactly the
phenomena and i don't i don't know how
much of it is like conscious i think
part of it is that like human beings are
deceitful to themselves and so like when
they're on the on the losing side and
the underside they have this like
genuine feeling that principles ought to
be important and when they're on the
winning side and the dominant side they
have this feeling that i don't know
principles don't matter like what
matters is accomplishing my objective i
have the the dune quote from frank
herbert the writer children of dune when
i'm weaker than you i ask for freedom
because that is according to your
principles but when i'm stronger than
you i take away your freedom because
that is according to mine to mine
yeah to my principles yeah sorry i got
up in the middle that was a little
anticlimactic so pop up but i think i
think that's like the phenomenon you
know we need a new word geez
a lot you know so the the right says
communism the left says capitalism
there's a corruption element there the
left says fascism
we need a new word you know what's
happening is a new type of prior um
proprietary technocracy
kind of but that doesn't explain it it
does i think cover a lot of what's
happening
but uh
you know you look at what's happening
with authoritarianism rule by edict how
does
proprietary technocracy explain joe
biden saying i hereby decree because he
can reach a trillion people a million
people with once with radio he uses
technology to like that's what hitler
did too he was a team yeah but radio is
150 years old or whatever yeah hitler
did a lot right right so that's always
convincing people with mass media it's
not a proprietary technique if he didn't
have the ability to stand up and say it
and everyone hears it on tv i don't
think that we it would have that kind of
impact
it's it's it's
technocracy is a government controlled
society by technical experts yeah
so we we certainly have a
twitter banned
biden thing but that doesn't explain joe
biden
that doesn't explain joe biden coming
out with an edict and then everyone just
adhering it was on my twitter page when
i loaded twitter for like five days did
you know that what he did isn't illegal
yes there's legal experts says
that's why i'm saying we need a new
world usurp the government
element of big tech corporations
wielding their power
but it's not so much the technology mass
media has been around for a long time it
is you have the private sector and the
public sector have merged which some
people might say is fascism but fascism
is also like traditionalist and
nationalistic so that doesn't explain
what they are they're they're it so we
need a word that represents
global corporatism
with state you know yeah global
government corporatism a word for all of
that in one thing
[Laughter]
global government corporatism
corporation goes global corporation goes
global yeah you've got private
corporations working in collusion with
the state under the under the uh mask
under the guise of democracy towards a a
a you know global international
new world order is that what they said
is that what laurie lightfoot said
i don't know that's what that australian
lady said so communism means something
fascism means something capitalism means
something and so when you're trying to
describe this i hear all these different
words thrown out and it's like it
doesn't capture the essence it's
definitely a corporatism like we were
talking about earlier with contracts if
a company has owns the rights to your
likeness and then they start building
artificial intelligence generative deep
fakes and can make you
look real and say whatever they want
forever
that's like you're a digital slave to a
corporation so like disney owns the
rights to thor they can make chris
hemsworth's face say anything they want
on a cartoon or on a tv show now do you
think it's all driven by corporations
no it's it's what's happening is there's
a a very dense powerful corporate
centralization of power
that is colluding with a very dense
centralization of government power
tour and and it's and it's it's
authoritarian it's detrimental to the
working class to the people it's
exploitative it's it enslaves it is
overtly authoritarian
and so
what's the word i you know i typically
would say the lucrative merger of
corporation and state would be fascism
mussolini's fascism but then you get all
sorts of arguments about the fascists
were traditionalists they were like you
know women you know at the home and
that's not what these people are these
people are ultra progressives but
they're not communists because they bel
they they work with corporations so it's
like chinese state
capitalist like it's it's chinese
communist capitalism it's like woke
neo-liberal corporatism but there should
be just one yeah no obviously yeah yeah
i'm going to start naming it i'm going
to say techno technocracy final answer
because without the social media none of
this could be happening what's
fascination oh that's not true ian
without the government that twitter
wouldn't have the legal protections to
make it happen oh
with that without the government twitter
could do whatever they wanted without
the democrats coming in so when when
when congress comes in and gives special
protections to the tech industry they're
then able to propaganda yeah i do i will
say i think a lot like a lot of big tech
is protected by federal laws like i was
talking to you about this before the
show i'll talk about this idea maybe a
little bit now about like there is an
ability to like they're a technical
ability but not a legal one
to embrace and extend these platforms
where you build like a facebook two
you log into it with your facebook
credentials and it gives you everything
in facebook one plus more and when you
comment on facebook too it backports the
facebook one for the people who are
still on there and and so on and this is
a way that we could evolve our way out
of
the status quo so we wouldn't be trapped
in this equilibrium that no one is happy
with
it's laws that stop these things from
being built so the big tech companies
use laws to shut down competitors i mean
the fact that i mean you know ip is a
big one you know you're still 10 you
know apple owns rounded black corners
you know uh oracle uh
i i think they ended up losing the case
but it went on for 10 years where oracle
potentially owned the set of java apis
which made it so that you know you
couldn't be competitive with phones
there's the uh computer fraud anti-abuse
act this is a big one that a lot of
people don't know about um
it says like basically unauthorized
access to a computer is a federal crime
and what these big tech companies do is
they say well if you're scraping public
data and we tell you to stop you're now
violating the cfaa and that's a federal
credit they don't even tell you to stop
the government just literally says yeah
we decided it's a crime but this kills
pad mapper if anyone remembers that
service yeah that was illegal it was uh
it was it was showing apartments on a
map so you could pull my map and it
would show you listings for rentals yeah
there's a there was a there was a
small companies like one guy he built
this service where southwest changed
their flight fees it would tell you
because if you call southwest when they
lower the price of the flight they'll
give you the money back but you have to
contact them
and southwest said stop scraping our
site and if you don't we're going to
call the fbi
so you can't look up our i guess our
public price data you know government
government
misappropriation of government can can
stifle
innovation but no government allows
corporations to send armed men into the
other startups and and kill everyone in
the building and then make sure that no
one starts out well all right so that i
mean that's a that's a much different
debate as to like how how would how do
you know how would these competing
interests play out in terms of violence
and i'm not gonna if we want to do the
like and cap first minor key debate we
can do it but i think that's separate
from like we can assume a minute so we
can assume there's some small government
that stops the companies from doing that
but if they didn't have these additional
laws that that that they were allowed to
leverage to shut down their competitors
i actually think competition would be
more i think you're right about that big
time actually
so um
repeal the cfa build an island in the
middle
we could build islands and live on them
i mean i i don't know i'm an optimist
like i think i think and this is why the
world is getting better despite
government getting worse entrepreneurs
always win human creativity always wins
human ingenuity the ability for humans
to be creative to come together to work
together to come up with novel solutions
like
i i think it's why the world continues
to get better and i think it's why i
think we'll get out of where we are with
the big tech stuff part of what's
frustrating about it is it takes time it
takes time for the new solutions i mean
you've had minds on you're having me on
uh you know i run library and which also
owns odyssey and you know these things
they're getting big odyssey grew from
nothing
to 40 million people a month in a year
you know like and it just takes time to
grow to a billion people no matter how
fast you're growing what do you think
about federating minds and library yeah
i would i'm i'm all for interoperability
uh and you know and that's part of the
beauty of all this stuff and and when
everything is open source when
everything is permissionless we're able
to innovate
so much faster and i think all of the
creative energy like you know google
google's a zombie man
like the smartest most creative people
they don't want to work at google they
don't want to work under a culture where
you have to adhere to awoke ideology and
if you don't you're going to lose your
job they don't want to sit through three
hours of diversity and inclusion
workshops a week and have to go through
all that training and have to put you
know pronouns in their signature and all
this stuff i'm not saying none of them
do but most of them don't i was thinking
last night google is it just that it's
too big
it's it's part of it's that it takes
just such a long time look i mean ibm
has been like sleepwalking for more than
a decade and it's still such a large
company um you know look it it doesn't
usually happen overnight where some
startup takes down the incumbent and so
when you're going through that five to
ten year reality which is how long it
actually takes for these things to play
out it feels really slow and it feels
like it's never going to happen but i
think it's happening i think it's
happening right now i think we're
undergoing it's like a constant a
resurgence and and then it falls away
and then fertilizes the soil where new
things appear with google i remember
when google plus came out and they had
youtube and google plus and it was like
why didn't they just make youtube the
social network they didn't they were
trying to and then they had this company
this partner that running google plus
running youtube and they didn't know
what the other hand was doing and it was
a mess youtube was trying to turn uh
google was trying to turn youtube into
google plus and it was backfiring bad it
was causing a lot of problems but the
intent it was happening was that youtube
would be google plus and then they were
like it's not working yeah so it makes
me think that it's too big that you
can't it's just too much authority and
too many levels of authority of things
getting passed down that it's less
effect loses affectivity yeah no that's
a and that's a such an important concept
and i think it's a mistake a lot of
people make in their thinking is they
think of like oh google's like a
coherent entity like oh the ceo just
says stuff and then like things happen
it's like you know when true of
government sometimes large corporations
well no but it's a bunch of individual
agents all with their own like local
incentives and a lot of times inside of
the large thing they're competing
interests they're competing branches of
government that are at odds with one
another they're competing factions of
google that are loud with one another
there's not an ability for one person to
just issue some top-down order and then
everything happens and and the most
creativity the best stuff happens when
you have people with that bottom-up
incentive where they believe in the
mission and they want to do the right
thing like very few
jobs especially creative work can be
like purely quantified where it's like
you oh produce your 40 widgets of stuff
and we're going to win because we're
producing 40 widgets of creativity per
week and we're you know highly it's not
the way it works it's not the way
true creation happens thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you